it's a gay film which i'm so happy to be
a part of it never focuses on anything
to do with being gay or any of the
lesbian relationships that are occurring
throughout the film it just kind of
accepts them as fact it was so nice to
be around other queer people too and
having that community where i felt safe
to be me
and
let my freak [ __ ] fly stupid for you
navigates the clumsiness of young love
and the crazy things we'll do for a
crush can you think of something
the craziest thing you might have done
to get the attention of someone that
you've had your eye on i'm the type of
person who's like
i looked at you once therefore you
should know i'm in love with you
also screening it inside out
unidentified objects i mean queer cinema
yes
can i already tell this is going to be
amazing
yeah
so amazing
sarah takes on the role of a spirited
sex worker who falls in platonic love
with her openly gay neighbor played by
matthew jeffers he is such a
professional and i am a total goofball
screw-up
he brought a professionalism out of me
that i need and i brought a little bit
of a goof out of him the film follows
the unlikely duo on a kooky road trip to
canada in search of aliens
you you want to drive to canada god oh
being locked in a car with somebody for
you know
20 days is it's intense all of this
stuff in movies you can fake but two
people in a car is the one thing that is
always just going to be two people in a
car
yeah and somebody passes gas that's
the road
also at the festival out in the ring a
documentary exploring the rich history
of lgbtq plus wrestlers and their fight
for respect and representation to be
able to take something that i grew up
loving so much and then look at it
through a queer lens
was really exciting for me how do you
hope that this
film
changes people's perceptions of the
lgbtq plus community with regards to pro
wrestling every wrestler is different
every wrestler is unique
and when it comes down to it in the ring
anybody can differ i think there's a lot
to learn and a lot to understand and
hopefully along the way maybe we can
make a couple of new fans